[Music]
the Chinese with a younger old wear silk
in both winter and summer they're ruling
classes where the finest silk other
classes where whatever quality they can
afford in winter the men wear two pairs
of trousers or three four or five or
even more pairs according to what they
can afford this they do in order to keep
the lower parts of their bodies warm on
account of the prevalence of damp and
the fear of its ill effects in summer
they where a singl gown of silk or
something of that sort they do not wear
turbans their staple food is rice they
often cook a sauce to go with it which
they pour on the rice before eating it
they're ruling classes however eat wheat
bread and the flesh of all sorts of
animals including pigs and other such
creatures there various kinds of fruit
apples peaches Citron's pomegranates
quinces pears bananas sugar cane
watermelons figs grapes serpent melons
cucumbers - jubie's walnuts almonds
hazelnuts pistachios apricots service
berries and coconuts
not many date palms are to be found in
China except for the occasional specimen
in the garden of a private home their
drink is a wine made from rice grape
wine is not to be found in their land
and it is never imported indeed they do
not know of it and do not drink it from
rice they manufacture vinegar wine
jellied sweet meats and other such
products
the Chinese are unhygenic and they do
not wash their backsides with water
after defecating but merely wipe
themselves with Chinese paper they eat
carrion and other similar things just as
the margins do in fact their religion
resembles that of the margins their
women folk leave their heads uncovered
but put combs in their hair single woman
often wearing 20 combs of ivory and and
other such materials the men folk
however cover their heads with something
like a cap in dealing with thieves their
practice is to put them to death if they
are caught it is said that the king of
China has more than 200 major cities
under his rule each of which has its own
King and eunuch chief of finance as well
as several lesser cities under its
governance among their major cities is
can fou the port for shipping which has
20 lesser cities under it her City is
only designated as such if it has JA
dams a jedem is an instrument that is
blown like a like a trumpet but longer
and of such a girth that both hands are
needed to grasp and encircle it it is
varnished with the substance used on
Chinese lacquer ware and reaches three
or four cubits in length and one end
narrow enough for a man to place his
mouth it's sound travels about a mile
every city is four gates and each is
equipped with five jams which are blown
at certain times of the night and the
day each city is also equipped with ten
kettle drums which are beaten when the
Jew dams are sounded the object of all
this is to proclaim their obedience to
the king it also enables them to know
the times of night and day in addition
they have indicators to regulate the
hours
they use copper coins for their
transactions and although their
Treasuries are like those of other
rulers no other ruler has copper as the
sole currency of the land they do indeed
possess gold silver pearls brocade and
silks and all in large quantities but
all those are regarded as items of
Commerce or the copper coins alone are
used as currency ivory frankincense and
copper ingots are all imported into
China as well as dable from the sea
which are the shells from Turtles backs
and the Bouchon which we've already
described namely the rhinoceros whose
horns they make into belts
among the many types of animals they use
for transport they do not possess Arab
horses but have other breeds instead
they also have donkeys and many
two-humped camel they have a fine type
of clay that is made into cups as
delicate as glass when held up to the
light the liquid in them can be seen
through the body of the cup even though
it is of clay as soon as the sea
merchants put into harbour the Chinese
take charge of their goods and transport
them to warehouses guaranteeing
indemnity for up to six months that is
until the last of the sea merchants
arrive then three tenths of the goods
are taken in kind as duty and the
remainder is returned to the merchants
any goods that the ruler needs he also
takes but he gives the very highest
price for them and pays immediately so
he does no harm to the merchants among
the goods he buys is a cam for paying
fifty fukuchi s for a mound the Fang a
thousand copper coins the same cam for
if the ruler had not bought it would be
worth only half that price on the open
market when one of the Chinese dies
he's not buried until the anniversary of
his death in the intervening period they
placed the body in a coffin and leave it
in their house
put quicklime on the corpse which
absorbs the fluids from it so that it
remains uncooperative their rulers
aarambam din aloes and camp for they
weep over the dead for three years all
who do not weep whether women or men are
beaten with wooden staves and they say
to them do you not grieve for your dead
eventually the Dead buried in graves
like the graves of the Arabs up until
the time of burial however they keep on
giving food to the dead person for they
maintain that he eats and drinks they
leave the food by the corpse at night
and when next morning they find none of
it left they say he has eaten it they do
not cease weeping over the corpse and
giving it food as long as it remains in
the house indeed they will impoverish
themselves for the sake of their dead
and will spend every last penny and sell
every last plot of land and spend the
proceeds to this end in former times
when they enter the king they used to
bury him with all his household
possessions such as robes and belts
their belts being worth large sums of
money but they have now abandoned the
practice because one of these royal dead
was dug up and the accompanying goods
looted the Chinese whether poor or rich
young or old all learn how to form
letters and to write the titles of their
rulers depend on their rank on on the
size of the cities they govern in the
case of a smaller City its ruler is
entitled to sons the meaning of two sons
being he set the affairs of the city
straight in the case of a major city
like Kant fou the title of its ruler is
defu the eunuch chief of Finance is
called the to come the eunuchs come from
their own people and are deliberately
castrated the Chief Justice is called
lakhs Imam kun and there are other
titles of this sort that we cannot set
down accurately
no one is given the office of ruler if
he is the less than 40 years old so they
say that someone of this age experience
has taught him when one of the lesser
rulers sits for a public hearing in the
city he sits on a judgement seat in a
large courtyard with another seat placed
before him and written submissions
concerning the legal proceedings of the
populace are presented to him behind the
ruler stands a man called a lick who and
if the ruler makes a slip in any of his
pronouncements and gets it wrong this
official rejects the decision they give
no considerations to anything a
petitioner has to say unless it is set
down in writing moreover before a
litigant enters the rulers presence his
written submission is examined by a man
who stands the palace gate and looks
over each person's documents if it
contains an error he rejects it
consequently only a scribe
well-acquainted with a legal law will
write anything to be submitted to the
ruler furthermore he has to write on the
document written by so-and-so son of
so-and-so so that if it does contain an
error the blame falls on the scribe and
he will be beaten with wooden staves the
ruler never sits in judgment until he
has eaten and drunk lest he judge
wrongfully in contrast to these
provincial rulers the great king is seen
in public only every ten months free
says if the people see me more often
they will look on me with a less
reverence successful rulership calls for
display of kingly pride the common
people have no idea of fairness in a
ruler so haughty attitude should be
adopted towards them in order to
increase our importance in their eyes
their landed property is not subject to
attacks indeed they themselves a taxed
per capita of the male population
according to the authorities estimation
of individual circumstances in the case
of any Arab or other foreigner resident
in the land a tax is paid on his
property in order to safeguard that
property if the price of grain Rises too
high the ruler releases stocks from his
granaries and sells it at less than the
market price causing the inflation to
end the income of the public treasury
comes from the poll tax I believe that
the daily income from the public
treasury in can Fuu is as much as fifty
thousand dinars even though it is not
the greatest of the cities among the
country's minerals the ruler has
exclusive rights to salt he also has the
rights to applaud that they drink with
hot water and it is sold in every city
for large sums of money called sack it
is the fear than alfalfa and a little
more aromatic with a bitterness to it to
prepare it water is boiled then the
leaves are sprinkled on it and it serves
them as an antidote to all ailments the
entire income of the public treasury
consists of the poll tax and the
receipts from salt and this plant
in every city there is something called
the der ah this is a bell hanging over
the head of the ruler of the city and
connected to a cord stretching until it
passes over the middle of the highway
for the use of all the common people the
distance between the ruler and the
highway is about far sac if the cord is
moved even slightly the Bell moves to
anyone who has a complaint against
injustice moves the cord causing the
Bell to move over the rulers head the
complainant is then permitted to enter
the rulers presence so that he may
deliver in person an account of his
circumstances and set forth his
grievance this procedure is used
throughout the land
anyone wanting to travel from one part
of China to another obtains two
documents one from the ruler and one
from the eunuch chief of Finance the
document from the rule there is a permit
for the road made out in the name of the
traveller and those accompanying him and
stating his age and his companions ages
and the tribe from which he comes all
persons in China whether of its native
population or the Arabs or other
foreigners are required to declare their
ancestral origin from some group with
which they may be officially identified
the second document from the eunuch
concerns the travelers money and any
goods he may have the reason for this
procedure is that there are guard posts
on the road where they examine both
documents and when a traveller arrives
at one they write so-and-so son of
so-and-so and such and such an origin
arrived at our guard post on the enth
day of the enth month of the enth year
accompanied by so-and-so this is in
order that none of the travelers money
or goods should go missing whenever
anything is actually lost or a traveler
dies the manner in which this occurred
will be known and his property returned
to him or his heirs the Chinese act
fairly where financial dealings or
deaths are concerned if someone makes a
loan to another person he writes a
document to the borrower obliging him to
repay the borrower also writes a
document to the lender marking it with a
mark between his two fingers the middle
and index finger the two documents have
been placed together and folded in on
each other and an inscription is written
across both of them at the place where
the edge is drawn and the recipient of
the loan receives his copy and
acknowledges his debt subsequently if
one of the parties should repudiate the
other he is taught to reduce his copy of
the document it may then happen that the
debtor maintains that he does not have
one were upon the creditors copy in the
debtors own handwriting and with his
mark can be presented his proof in such
a case a debtor who still repudiate his
creditor will be told
use another document then stating that
this sum is not owed by you and if you
cannot and the creditors claim which you
have repudiated is shown to be beyond
dispute then you will be made to suffer
20 blows on the back with wooden staves
and to pay twenty thousand fuku G's of
copper coins the fine would amount to
around two thousand dinars while the 20
blows would be enough to kill him no one
in China would willingly bring that upon
himself for fear of ruining both his
person and his property and we never
have seen anyone have to undergo it
consequently they act fairly towards
each other
[Music]
they have a stone tablet setup 10 cubits
tall on which is written in engraved
characters a list of remedies and
diseases each particular disease paired
with its appropriate remedy and if a
sick person is poor he is given the cost
of his medicine from the public treasury
when a male child is born to anyone his
name is registered with the ruler and
when he reaches the age of 18 he has to
pay the poll tax if however he lives to
the age of 80 he no longer has to pay
the tax instead he is given a pension
from the public treasury before they say
when he was young he paid us a tax now
he is old we pay him a pension also
every city has a school and a teacher to
teach the poor how to write and the
children of the poor are fed from the
public treasury there is a village in
the mountains in China called
Tai Yu where the people are short in
stature every sure person in China is
said to come from there
the Chinese are a fine-looking tool
people with clear pale complexions
tinged with red no people have black a
hair than they
[Music]
you